[Musique]
il ya deux cents ans de nice et le poète
réunionnais leconte de lisle
le conseil départemental a décidé de
célébrer ce bicentenaire tout au long de
l'année et de le faire vivre dans toute
l'île le conduit sa réunionnais qui a
passé
plusieurs années dans son île et qui a
mis la réunion en l'air comme on dirait
aujourd'hui à son époque donc dans la
seconde moitié du 19e siècle c'est
quelqu'un qui s'est battu également pour
la cause des esclaves et c'est avant
tout j'aurais peut-être dû commencer par
ça un grand poète en germe la
littérature française mais reconnue
mondialement de saint jean la
littérature la bibliothèque
départementale de la réunion a donc
inauguré son exposition des oeuvres de
leconte de lisle dans les collections
patrimoniales des établissements
culturels de la collectivité
nous fêtons cette année le bicentenaire
de leconte de lisle et nous pouvons dire
que le département est fier parce que
dans cette mise en place de l'année du
bicentenaire le compte de lille nous
pouvons exposer aujourd'hui ici à la
bibliothèque départementale
tout ce que nous possédons tous les
trésors que nous possédons dans
nos structures au département un
panorama extraordinaire des ouvrages et
des éditions originales
écrit par le compte de lille pour edgar
pic spécialiste des oeuvres du poète
il s'agit là de pièces très rares je
suis je dois le dire et je ne le cache
pas vraiment ébloui par ce que il y en
aurait pu imaginer une exposition qui
présente tout simplement quelques images
pour dire souvenez-vous mais ce n'est
pas ça du tout du tout du tout
c'est une vision tout à fait tout à fait
tout à fait bien informée qui met
l'accent sur des choses remarquables et
pas toujours assez vu mais ici nous
voyons réellement est clairement ce que
le compte de lille a été évidemment il
faut apporter des explications mais
l'essentiel c'est l'exposition à qui je
souhaite un très très grand succès et
qui le mérite
la bibliothèque départementale souhaite
maintenir cette exposition durant
plusieurs mois
[Musique]